el proceso de selección natural es en
cierta medida dependiente de la idea de
la variación la idea de que en cualquier
población de una misma especie hay
variación genética por ejemplo si
tenemos a la especie de los círculos y
uno de los círculos es de color amarillo
y por acá estos círculos son de este
otro color y por alguna razón en algunas
ocasiones no hay factores ambientales
que predispongan a algunos de los
individuos de una especie para poder
sobrevivir o reproducirse más
frecuentemente que los demás pero de vez
en cuando si hay factores ambientales
que pueden hacer que de pronto este
círculo sea más apto para reproducirse y
así por la razón que sea este círculo es
capaz de reproducirse con mayor
frecuencia y estos círculos se
reproducen con menor frecuencia algunos
de ellos los matan son comidos por
pájaros o lo que sea o simplemente no
son capaces de reproducirse por la razón
que sea y luego tal vez estos círculos
son un caso en medio y a medida que pasa
el tiempo la frecuente
de los diferentes rasgos que ves en esta
población cambiará y si son los
suficientemente drásticos tal vez estos
círculos se convierten en dominantes y
empiezan a dejar de gustarles estos
otros círculos porque son muy diferentes
o cualquier otra razón y ellos a la
larga podrían convertirse en una especie
diferente ahora la pregunta obvia es qué
es lo que lleva a esta variación en una
población en nuestra población por
ejemplo qué es lo que lleva a que una
persona tenga el cabello rubio una
persona tenga el cabello castaño otro
tenga el cabello negro y también tenemos
un muy amplio espectro de colores de
piel y estaturas que es prácticamente
infinito cuál es la causa de esto y una
de las cosas que se podrían mencionar
aquí y hablamos de esto un poco en el
vídeo de adn son las mutaciones ya vimos
que el adn es solo una secuencia de
bases nitrogenadas
avn in a guanina digamos que tengo algo
de timina también un poco más de adenina
citosina y citosina si tenemos
suficientes de estas bases en una fila
tal vez unos cientos o unos pocos miles
de ellas estas codifican para las
proteínas y codifican para las cosas que
controlan otras proteínas y tal vez
ocurre un cambio en una de ellas tal vez
estas y tocina por cualquier razón se
convierte en una guanina o tal vez estas
son eliminadas y eso cambiaría el adn te
puedes imaginar que se utilizará la
computadora de alguien y me pusiera a
cambiar el código fuente si le cambiaran
las letras y aleatoriamente le agregara
otras letras sin saber realmente lo que
estoy haciendo la mayoría de las veces
voy a descomponer el programa de la
computadora la gran mayoría de las veces
estas mutaciones no van a llevar a
ningún lado
ninguna
por ejemplo si agregar a un par de
espacios al código fuente de una
computadora
probablemente no generaría ningún cambio
pero si me pusiera a borrar los puntos y
cambiarán los números probablemente
descompondría el programa por lo que una
mutación podría o bien no hacer nada o
bien podría matar al organismo
mutaciones
en ocasiones las mutaciones podrían
hacer que la célula se salga de control
y vamos a hacer una serie de vídeos
acerca del cáncer y esto en sí
perjudicaría al organismo aunque si
ocurre después de que el organismo se
haya reproducido puede que no sea algo
que seleccionó el organismo y tampoco se
transmitiría las siguientes generaciones
pero de todos modos no voy a entrar a
detalle en eso el punto es que las
mutaciones no parecen ser una buena
fuente de variación podrían ser una de
las fuentes o bien podrían contribuir a
esto pero debe haber algo más profundo
que las mutaciones que está creando
diversidad o variación incluso dentro de
una población y la respuesta aquí
podríamos decir que está justo en frente
de nosotros y hace alusión a uno de los
conceptos más fundamentales de la
biología y es tan fundamental que una
gran cantidad de personas ni siquiera se
cuestionan porque sucede de esta manera
y eso es la reproducción sexual
y reproducción
sexual
y cuando hablo de la reproducción sexual
es esta noción de que si nos fijamos en
la mayoría de los organismos cuyas
células tienen núcleos las cuales son
llamadas células eucariotas o células
eucariontes sus poblaciones están
conformadas por machos y hembras en
algunos casos un mismo organismo puede
ser ambos macho y hembras pero la idea
en común aquí es que todos estos
organismos producen versiones de su
material genético que se mezclan con
otras versiones de material genético de
otros organismos si las mutaciones
fueran la única fuente de variación
entonces yo podría simplemente crear
otras versiones de mí
tal vez estas otras versiones
simplemente se desprenderían de mí y
luego aleatoriamente una de ellas podría
ser un poco diferente
pero eso como ya dijimos nos daría muy
poca variación y cualquier variación que
pudiera ocurrir debido a cualquier tipo
de ruido que se introduzca en este
proceso en el que me replicó a mí misma
la mayoría de las veces tendría un
efecto negativo en el organismo ahora
bien qué sucede cuando se tiene la
reproducción sexual bueno sigues
haciendo todas las posibles
combinaciones de adn así que permítanme
hacer esto un poco más concreto voy a
borrar este dibujo y voy a hablar de los
humanos tenemos 23 pares de cromosomas y
cada par está conformado por un
cromosoma de nuestra madre y un
cromosoma de nuestro padre permítanme
hacer esto voy a dibujar los cromosomas
de mi padre en azul tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
v 20 21 22 y luego voy a dibujar otro
aquí que es un poco diferente se parece
a una y y más adelante hablaremos acerca
de los cromosomas x ii y iii tengo 23
cromosomas de mi madre que voy a dibujar
en color rosa así que tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20
21 22 y 23 entonces tengo 23 cromosomas
de mi madre
y 23 cromosomas de mi padre voy a hacer
un acercamiento a un par de ellos así
que digamos que nos fijamos en este
cromosoma le vamos a llamar cromosoma
número 3
recuerda que el cromosoma es una cadena
muy larga de adn la cadena de adn se
envuelve alrededor de todas estas
proteínas y se crea esta estructura y
esto podría tener millones de pares de
bases así que se ve algo así y así es
como se dibujan normalmente aunque el
cromosoma no siempre se encuentra de
esta manera pero hablaremos más acerca
de eso más adelante así que digamos que
este cromosoma es de mi madre y este es
de parte de mi padre ahora vamos a
llamar a este cromosoma 3 los dos son
cromosoma 3 y la idea aquí es que estoy
recibiendo diferentes rasgos de mi padre
y de mi madre y estoy haciendo una
simplificación excesiva aquí pero estoy
solo para darles la idea de lo que está
pasando este cromosoma 3
tal vez contenga la información para el
tipo de cabello y tal vez mi padre tenía
el cabello lacio así que en algún lugar
de este cromosoma hay un gen
para el cabello lacio digamos que se
encuentra aquí y recuerda este gen
podría estar conformado por miles de
pares de bases
pero digamos que este es el gen para el
cabello lacio o que esta es la versión
del gen o el alelo para el cabello lacio
y recuerda un alelo es una versión de un
gen y lo llamaré alelo lacio
para el cabello lacio ahora este otro
cromosoma que me dio mi madre existen
algunas excepciones pero en su mayor
parte codifica para los mismos genes que
este cromosoma de mi padre y por eso los
coloqué uno al lado del otro así que
este también tendrá el gen para el tipo
de cabello y en este caso codifica para
el cabello rizado así que aquí está la
versión del gen o el alelo al que
llamaremos rizado el gen dictará el tipo
de cabello dictara si tu cabello es
rizado o no y cada versión del gen es
llamada alelo ahora bien cuando tengo
estos dos en mis células y esto se
encuentra en cada célula de mi cuerpo
cada célula de mi cuerpo a excepción de
iu hablaremos de esto en un momento más
a excepción de mis game
pero todas las células que no sean las
células utilizadas para la reproducción
tienen este conjunto completo de
cromosomas que es algo que me parece
increíble pero por ejemplo estos genes
que codifican para el tipo de cabello no
serían útiles en las células de mis uñas
y estoy simplificando esta idea
podríamos decir que en ciertos lugares
de mi cuerpo no tienen una función así
que ciertos genes se expresan en ciertas
partes del cuerpo pero cada una de las
células de tu cuerpo a las que llamamos
células somáticas tienen todos estos
cromosomas y vamos a diferenciarlas de
las células sexuales o germinales de las
que hablaremos más adelante así que
estas son las células del cuerpo y son
la gran mayoría de tus células y también
tenemos células germinales
y simplemente para que tengas una idea
clara de estas células estás originan en
los hombres a los espermatozoides
y en las mujeres
a los óvulos
pero la mayoría de mis células tienen
una colección completa de estos
cromosomas y lo que quiero es darte la
idea de que por cada rasgo tengo dos
versiones una de mi madre y una de mi
padre
ahora estos se llaman cromosomas
homólogos
cromosomas
lo que esto significa es que cada vez
que ves este prefijo como por ejemplo en
la palabra homosexual o homogénea como
significa igual
así homólogo significa que son casi
iguales la mayor parte de estos
cromosomas está codificando para el
mismo conjunto de genes pero no son
idénticos podrían codificar para
versiones ligeramente diferentes del
mismo gen así que dependiendo de las
versiones que tengo se forma mi genotipo
genotipo
mi genotipo es exactamente los alelos
que tengo las versiones que tengo de
cada gen así que digamos que tengo la
quinta versión del alelo rizado podría
haber varias versiones del alelo rizado
en nuestro acervo genético y tal vez me
dieron alguna versión del alelo lacio
ese es mi genotipo mi fenotipo es la
apariencia de mi cabello por ejemplo dos
personas pueden tener genotipos
diferentes pero podría ser que su
cabello se vea muy similar es decir
tendrían fenotipos muy similares así que
un fenotipo puede ser representado por
múltiples genotipos distintos y esto lo
menciono solo como una reflexión y
hablaremos más acerca de esto en el
futuro por ahora solo quiero introducir
estos conceptos ahora toda esta
discusión se debe a que quería hablar
acerca de la variación así que como
sucede la variación pues bien qué ocurre
cuando una persona se reproduce digamos
que es un hombre y digamos que tiene un
hijo la contribución del padre al hijo
va a ser una colección
aleatoria de la mitad de estos genes por
cada para homólogo el padre va a
contribuir o bien con el cromosoma que
obtuvo de su madre o con el que obtuvo
de su padre así que digamos que el
espermatozoide que pasó a fertilizar el
óvulo de su esposa tenía este cromosoma
y este otro y podríamos elegir uno azul
o uno rosa de cada uno de estos 23 pares
y te puedes estar preguntando cuántas
combinaciones hay bueno porque a la par
podrías escoger uno de los dos
cromosomas homólogos y voy a hacer eso
23 veces así que es 2 elevado a la
vigesimotercera potencia así que hay 2 a
la 23 versiones diferentes con las que
el hombre puede contribuir a cualquier
hijo o hija que pueda tener y vamos a
hablar de cómo sucede esto cuando
hablemos de la mitosis y la meiosis que
cuando se generan los espermatozoides en
lugar de tener 23 pares de cromosomas en
un espermatozoide hay 23 cromosomas por
se va a tomar uno de cada parte y a
través del proceso de la meiosis que
vamos a ver más adelante se van a
generar un montón de espermatozoides y
cada espermatozoide tendrá un cromosoma
de cada uno de estos pares así que tal
vez este cromosoma proviene de mi padre
el siguiente cromosoma lo obtengo de mi
madre y por acá tengo otros dos más que
vienen de mi mamá y el cromosoma número
5 viene de mi padre y así continúa pero
hay dos ala 23 combinaciones posibles
aquí porque hay 23 pares de cromosomas y
estoy obteniendo un cromosoma de cada
uno de esos pares ahora el óvulo de la
esposa va a tener la misma situación hay
dos ala 23 combinaciones diferentes de
adn con las que ella puede contribuir
así las posibles combinaciones que solo
una pareja puede producir y estoy usando
una pareja humana como ejemplo pero esto
se aplica a todas las especies que se
reproduzcan de manera sexual así que si
el hombre
puede contribuir con 2 a la 23
combinaciones de adn y la mujer puede
contribuir con 2 a la 23 combinaciones
de adn entonces juntos pueden producir 2
a la 46ª combinaciones ahora solo para
darte una idea de qué tan grande es este
número esto es aproximadamente 12 mil
veces el número de seres humanos que
vemos en el planeta hoy en día así que
hay una gran cantidad de variación que
una pareja puede producir y si pensabas
que eso no es suficiente pues resulta
que entre estos pares homólogos se puede
tener una recombinación de adn y esto
significa que cuando estos varios
homólogos durante la meiosis se colocan
cerca unos de los otros puede ocurrir un
entrecruzamiento cromosómico donde una
porción de adn de este cromosoma se
intercambia con una porción de adn de
este otro cromosoma así que esta parte
se va para allá y esta parte se va para
acá
y lo que se obtiene con este
entrecruzamiento es que el cromosoma que
provenía de mi madre ahora tiene un
trozo del cromosoma que proviene de mi
padre
y el cromosoma que provenía de mi padre
ahora tiene un trozo del que vino de mi
madre de modo que se aumenta la variedad
aún más así que ahora en lugar de hablar
de los diferentes cromosomas con los que
estás contribuyendo y las combinaciones
de cromosomas ahora estamos hablando de
combinaciones a nivel de los genes y
ahora se puede pensar en una cantidad
casi infinita de variaciones se puede
pensar en todas las variaciones que
pueden surgir cuando se mezclan y
combinan las diferentes versiones del
mismo gen en una población y no sólo nos
limitamos a ver un gen es decir la
realidad es que los genes por sí mismos
muy rara vez codifican para
características específicas muy rara vez
se puede ver un gen y decir oh
ese es el gen para el cabello castaño o
encontrar un gen y decir oh es el gen de
la inteligencia o el gen de la simpatía
por lo general es un conjunto de genes
que interactúan en una forma
increíblemente complicada el cabello
puede ser codificado por todo este
conjunto de genes
cromosomas y esto podría ser codificado
por todo este conjunto de genes en
varios cromosomas y así puedes empezar a
pensar en todas las diferentes
combinaciones y también tal vez en
alguna combinación que no existía antes
pero te dejaré que pienses en ello
porque tal vez esta combinación podría
ser transmitida o no
debido a esta recombinación pero
hablaremos más de eso en el futuro solo
quería introducir esta idea acerca de la
reproducción sexual porque esto
realmente es la principal fuente de
variación dentro de una población y a mí
me parece que es una idea filosófica
porque damos por hecho el que haya
hombres y mujeres ya que es una idea
universal pero estaba leyendo sobre esto
y resulta que esto surgió hace alrededor
de 1.4 miles de millones de años esto se
podría decir que es un rasgo útil porque
una vez que se introduce este nivel de
variación la selección natural puede
darse de una mejor forma es decir esta
forma de variación es mucho más potente
que las mutaciones
es más potente que alguna forma
primitiva de entrecruzamientos ahora que
tenemos la reproducción sexual y toda
esta variación la selección natural
puede ocurrir de una manera más
eficiente así que las especies que
fueron capaces de reproducirse y
recomendar su adn y mezclarlo y
combinarlo de esta manera pudieron
producir una mayor variedad y pudieron
ser seleccionados para su entorno de una
manera más eficiente por lo que
empezaron a superar en número a los que
no podían hacer esto por lo que esto se
convirtió en un rasgo universal pero
podrías imaginar un mundo y existen
libros de ciencia ficción escritos sobre
esto un mundo donde hay tres géneros
donde se tiene el género 1 2 y 3
podría haber 10 géneros diferentes sólo
que en la tierra esta noción de tener
dos géneros resultó ser a una forma muy
eficiente y estable de introducir
variación en una población así que
espero que hayas encontrado esto
interesante en el siguiente vídeo
veremos a detalle cómo funcionan la
mitosis